One thing that will make you disown your
child? Something mental. Yeah. Leaving
the religion. Mhm.
I feel that's big drip. You can't do
that one there.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> You know what I mean? But it have to be
>> if he said if he if he wanted to leave
um not be Muslim, you'd disown him?
Yeah, I'd say yo
that can't run for me. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
>> what I mean? Like I'm saying don't get
twisted. Don't get twisted.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is soul is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, Umrah, Salah, fasting?
What? No. Sadaqah. Brothers and sisters,
Iera is getting thousands of Shahadas
monthly, yearly, hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training Dawah. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that Sadaqah Jariyah
that goes on forever? This is how Islam
has spread around the world, brothers
and sisters. Carry on this legacy of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
inshallah by donating whatever amount
inshallah. And it's what Iera right now
inshallah. Enjoy the video. As-salamu
alaykum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh,
brothers and sisters in different. This
is a video that I saw a couple of days
ago while I was traveling to Netherlands
and I'm going to the Salah Plus Project,
Salah Pro Project. Alhamdulillah, 50,000
mats came. We delivered 3 and 1/2
thousand mats to Netherlands to all the
Dawah tables, to the mosques there,
alhamdulillah. And we're working closely
with them. So, here's a video of Chunkz.
So, this is a video that was going viral
and I hear where Chunkz was coming from.
However, there is some corrections to be
made inshallah and we know that it's for
his love for his religion that he said
what he said. But let's just some
context because we need to talk about
Islam says
and people can make statements, people
can make mistakes, people can Well,
human beings will make mistakes, I mean
mistakes. So, here's the video, let's
watch it for ourselves inshallah and see
what Chunkz have to say. One thing that
will make you disown your child? I could
forgive a lot, you know, when it comes
to my own youth. Something mental. Yeah.
Leaving the religion. Mhm.
I feel that's big drip. You can't do
that one there.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> You know what I mean? But it have to be
>> if he said if he if he wanted to leave
um not be Muslim, you'd disown him?
Yeah, I'd say yo
that can't run for me. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
>> mean? Like I'm saying don't get twisted.
Don't get twisted. You can leave it, but
you can also come back. Mhm. You get it?
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> But I feel like leaving the fold of
Islam
>> Yeah. I can't part with you, man.
>> Uh-huh. You know what I mean? Like I I I
know I'll always have that unconditional
love
>> Uh-huh. where I see the you and if I see
him in a in a past time, I'm always
going to try and stop it. But I feel
like having that want to love this
person without being under the fold of
Islam.
>> Yeah. I can't I can't I can't part with
that, man. Okay, so what you can see
that obviously you need to understand
he's coming from a place of his real
it's protective jealousy of his
religion. Okay, but we need to also look
at what Islam says. Okay, there is
nowhere in Islam that says that if your
child leaves the fold of Islam, you have
to disown them. There's nothing that
says that. So, you need to understand we
need to make that clear. When these
things happen, guys, we need to be
really, really understanding and be real
about it, okay?
Disowning them is going to just going to
make the situation worse. Unless you're
dealing with a full-blown enemy of
Islam, that's a different story. I'm
talking about someone who has a doubt,
someone who has some questions, someone
who has whatever it is for that matter.
If you look at Nuh Alaihis Salam and Lut
Alaihis Salam, okay? Their wives, yes,
some of their wives, their children.
Yes, Lut Alaihis Salam, his son was an
outright disbeliever. But you did not
see him uh Nuh Alaihis Salam, you did
not see him
disown his son. So much so that
subhanallah he made dua oh Allah protect
me and my family so when he was building
the ark. And so much so that when the
waves were coming, he said to his son,
"Oh my son, come on board." Uh even at
that level, he was asking and his son
was arrogantly saying, "No, I'm going to
climb to a high mountain and I'll be
saved." And he said, "Then no one's
going to save you from the wrath of
Allah this day." And when Nuh Alaihis
Salam in the boat made the dua crying,
he said, "Oh Allah, you promised me that
you will save me and my family." He was
upset about his son. Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala rebuked Nuh Alaihis Salam and
corrected him and said, "Oh Nuh,
your your only family is what? The
believers. Yes, make that clear."
Meaning what? Blood is thicker than
water, lineage, blood relations, yes?
Iman is thicker than blood. So, your
actual family members are who? The
believers. That's why in the Battle of
Badr you will see people who are
fighting their family members on the
other side. Yes? Because if it when it
all boils down, believe me,
it's going to be the people who have
Iman that are going to be together. That
is the reality. Okay, so subhanallah in
this matter we need to have evidence
from the Quran and Sunnah. We do not
have anything about disowning and we
need to be patient and give them the
Siyar. And we need to be patient and
talk to them and answer their doubts. Be
kind. This is not a correct attitude.
This is not from Hikmah, wisdom, yes, to
be like, "Oh, you left Islam, I'm going
to disown you." And I don't think Chunkz
means that because you need to
understand he doesn't have a child of
his own just yet and that will totally
change. Now, even then, it's a important
principle to be like, "Okay, I which I
believe this is where Chunkz is coming
from that my loyalty to Allah and His
Messenger. I don't give it to my child."
And I know it's easy to say. I have
three daughters and I would never want
that. However, that if it came to a
point where I know my daughter or if I
had a son and they are outright
insulting Allah, hell no. Bye-bye. Like
to me, Allah and His Messenger comes
first. But if they say, "I have some
doubts, I don't believe," they're
respectful and they have some doubts,
sometimes you keep them close and do
Dawah with your actions and words as
well inshallah, yes? And you have to be
patient because Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
tests. And like Chunkz said, you don't
know, they can come back to Islam. So,
don't write off people. So, I think this
is what Chunkz means and just to give it
context because Islamically
we can and we should have wisdom and be
careful and try to cater. And like Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala says, "Repel evil with
that which is good and you'll see the
one you have enmity, there will be
friendship." And it is important for us
to have this Hikmah and wisdom because
look, the Quran is like that. We cannot
have this black and white attitude. This
happened, no. There has to be patience.
There has to be correction. There has to
be mercy. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? And there has to be compassion and
empathy. So, subhanallah, we know what
Chunkz meant. He came from a place of
his love for his religion that is really
admirable. Subhanallah, it's actually to
me it's praiseworthy. It's just maybe
the way he worded it was a little bit
wrong. He's a human being. He's
corrected himself and that's all I have
to say inshallah, brothers and sisters.
May Allah bless and preserve you guys
inshallah. May Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
bless brother Chunkz, his family
inshallah.
And you guys that are watching at home,
I thought I'd do this video because it's
very important. There's a lot of
misconception that that that's
happening. We have to be patient. If Nuh
Alaihis Salam, Lut Alaihis Salam, Lut
Alaihis Salam
Nuh Alaihis Lut Alaihis Salam was going
to give his daughters to flipping
homosexuals, bro. To homosexuals who
were into men, who were saying, "Look, I
have daughters that you can marry." Yes?
Today, would you give your daughter to
an individual who has these
inclinations? Because Tawhid,
understanding the mission and
understanding what Islam came with, it's
more important than your cultural
beliefs and what I think, "Oh, I would
never." Look, if Lut Alaihis Salam done
it, what you trying to say, he was
wrong? Was Lut Alaihis Salam wrong? No.
He said, "Instead of committing this
act, marry my daughters." Subhanallah,
look at what they believed and look at
how we are today, subhanallah. May Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala make us among those
who follow the true form of Islam, not
our cultures and desires and all that
kind of stuff inshallah. Till next time,
as-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.